Thank you.
All right.
Welcome to our budget work session.
It is Tuesday, April 28th at 3.02.
And we'll go ahead and call this meeting to order.
The first item of business today, we're going to turn the time right over to Vince, our engineer,
to discuss some water and other items that he knows.
Sounds good.
Let me get this PowerPoint started here.
There we go.
So I have three different items to present to you today.
Water, wastewater, and our stormwater projects.
These are all capital projects that we're proposing to fund for next year.
First of all, water.
These projects on this slide are all projects that we're currently working on.
They're projects that are in different phases of actual completion.
I'll go through each one individually, but these are items that we have budgeted in past years.
We're going to roll that budget into the current fiscal year.
And then what you're seeing here are additional funds that we're requesting for this year to complete these projects.
Our 4 million gallon tank, that's the one up at Scarlet Ridge.
It's currently under construction.
The floor is completely poured.
A few of the columns are poured.
We have two wall sections that are poured.
And so they're pouring wall sections every one or two weeks.
And things are moving ahead well.
Things are looking good on that project.
I think overall project budget was around $2.5 million to complete it this year.
We're asking for the additional $700,000 just to wrap up construction.
Any questions on that one?
So $3.2 is the total overall cost for the construction of that tank?
Yep, approximately.
That's better than the last one we did, I think.
Upgrade well 5.
What we've done on well 5 to date, I guess first of all, well 5 is up hidden hollow.
Right behind the elementary school.
That pumps water up to our two different tanks that are up hidden hollow canyon up there.
Well 5 specifically, it has capacity to pump more water than we have a pump for at this time.
And so the upgrade on well 5 was upgrading pumps.
But in order to upgrade those pumps, of course, we have to upgrade all the electrical systems that go along with it.
And so we've installed a backup generator on that also.
All of those items are really long lead type of items.
And so we ordered those probably a year and a half ago.
Some of the items have arrived.
Some are still out there.
It should be getting close.
What we're budgeting for this year is to hire a contractor, get everything installed and ready to go.
Functional.
Benz, can you speak to the additional capacity that's going to give us?
What are we hoping to gain from that?
So I think right now, Mac would know better.
He's not here today.
But I think right now we're at 2,000 to 2,500 gallons per minute.
We're hoping to bump it up to 3,000, 3,500 gallons per minute.
So adding an extra 1,000 gallons per minute.
And then well 7 on Unity Pass.
That's the well that we've been drilling on for a year and a half or so.
Right off of Pony Express, right next to the middle school.
Or not the middle school.
The elementary school that's right there at Hidden Hollow.
Obviously, we've drilled it.
We have an engineer hired at Bowen and Collins.
They're doing the design on that.
That was all in the budget that we've already received in the past year.
For this next year, the plan is to build the well house, install the pumps, install all the electrical equipment.
And so this would be budgeting to complete that project with everything.
And so hopefully by the end of 2027, we would have another functioning well.
I'm going to bug you again.
What's the total overall cost then for that well?
The overall cost for that well?
I'm trying to remember what the drilling costs were.
I think they were close to $2 million for the drilling.
And so $4, $4.5 million.
Didn't we have some change orders along the way too?
Maybe Kimberly can speak to that.
Because I know that well has been in process for quite a number of years with bits that still live at the bottom and stuff.
So I think as we discussed with the driller, because he didn't make his actual goal.
We were trying to get down to 1,500 feet as far as depth.
He never got there.
He had issues with drilling heads, losing drilling heads down the hole and things like that.
And it was at a point where we were worried about losing the well completely and having to start all over.
And so because he didn't make all the way down to his full depth, we did negotiate with him.
And I think we came in under budget on that.
We didn't get the full depth, but we also didn't pay him everything that was in the original contract.
Well, I think that's what they need to know here is that it was a per foot bid, right, and he didn't get there.
So what was the amount maybe that we paid?
He was obviously a third short.
Did we short him a third money?
I know there was some change orders, so I don't...
Yeah, and it doesn't come out exactly even because there's mobilization costs and stuff that would have been the same no matter how deep he went.
So do we lose capacity then because he didn't get further down?
So when we did our pump test, after he had finished drilling, we were able to get over 3,000 gallons per minute.
And so it looks like it's a good well.
As far as production, the difference is if we would have gone all the way down to the 1,500, as our aquifer goes up and down, it will vary a lot from year to year.
And if we get into a drought cycle of multiple years, it will drop.
And there is a chance that we could drop it below where we drilled.
And so that's...
Is there a way to remedy that once we build the well house or...
I mean, you take the roof off and keep drilling?
Right.
There's really not.
No.
So we're at 1,000 feet.
We're at 1,000 feet.
Yeah, we can't go back and increase it.
Do we want to stop there?
Or is there an opportunity for us to get to the mark that we need to get to?
Or is this just, it is what it is now?
For this well, it is what it is.
I think what we'll do instead of that is make sure we have other wells in other places so we have redundant sources.
And so if we get to that point where we do draw our aquifer down that far, we have other sources.
So it'll be the first one that comes offline, basically.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Which brings us to well 9, which is basically a redundant well for well 7.
I mean, we do need the capacity because of the growth, but it is a redundant well also.
This one is at the end of Lone Tree, actually closer to the airport on the bottom end.
And this one, we have funding in the past funding cycle to start drilling on that.
And we're going to start, we've already hired a driller.
He's going to start in July just with timeframes and other things he had going on.
He can't start until July, but we'll get him drilling in July.
And so the funding that we had from last year for that drilling will move to the next year.
And then we'll just move on to the next steps of that one.
For this funding cycle, this $3.5 million will be full engineering design, and then well house pumps, all the electrical equipment.
This one also has a length of pipe, whereas the well 7, it was right next to Pony Express where we have pipelines that could tie right in.
And this one, we have to go a little ways with our pipelines, so you'll see it's a little more expensive than the other well, but it's because we're adding on a pipeline section to it also.
For what was in the current budget, Vince, for me, I'm just trying to, I recognize that each well is individual and different.
I mean, I understand that.
But I'm trying to just kind of draw some conclusions that we're about $4.5 million, $5 million to put in a well.
It's going to fluctuate a million, a million and a half, depending upon the issues that we have.
And our hope is that we're going to get 3,000 gallons per minute.
That's a good well.
I know that some of them don't produce that.
Drilling wells is a bit of a gamble.
Sure.
You know, that's why you hire somebody to water wage and tell you where to drill a hole.
So I'm just in my head.
I'm trying to wrap my head around all that.
So what did we have previously in our budget?
A million bucks?
Is that what we already budgeted for this, or do you know?
For the drilling?
I don't remember.
I don't know, Kimberly, if you have that number.
I believe originally, so when we do our wells, we typically will break it out into a couple
of different, so you have the drilling component, and then we'll have the pump house and connecting
the line to it.
So I do at least believe for well number nine, that the original was probably in the 3 million
to 3 and a half million, almost that number.
When we did Unity Pass, that project, just in drilling the well, not even the pump house
itself, was over a $5 million.
Typically, the drilling part for us, when we're looking at estimates, is about $3.5 million,
and then historically, it's been another $2.5 million, $3 million to do the pump house and
connect the line.
But I do know there's a lot, again, it depends on the train, everything that's involved with
it.
That's just helpful information to be able to share with the general public, that we're sometimes
$5 to $7 million to put in a well.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Real quick, are there any adjustments that need to be made to what we're asking for impact
fee-wise, if it's more than what we anticipate originally?
Yes.
And the process to that would be we would have to update our IFFP and get that approved, and
then go to the IFA and get that approved also.
And so there is a process to do that, and we're planning on more frequent updates than
we have done in the past to account for some of these rising costs.
As we know, there's been a lot of inflation in the last even couple of years that make
a big difference in our costs.
Do you know the last time, Steph, we did look at what our impact fees are for water specifically?
So I don't know the last time the IFA was approved officially, but we have one right now that's
under consideration that has all these numbers in it, and so you should be seeing that.
We'll bring it to council in a month or two.
Thank you.
Yep.
So these projects are all new projects.
As you can see, the top three are different sections of our SR-73 project.
And the reason I broke them out is because that's the way they were broken out in our master
plan.
Now, at this point, we're talking about trying to do these all at the same time so that
we get one continuous project, cheaper mobilization and things like that is just more efficient
to do them all at the same time if that's possible.
Can you just give us kind of a general idea of what work is being done in that project?
Yep.
In fact, I have a slide that kind of shows the area.
So this is Saratoga Springs over here.
This is SR-73.
So right up above SR-73 in Saratoga Springs, we have what we call the North Terminal Reservoir.
That's Central Utah's main reservoir.
They built it several years ago for this purpose.
Not just for Eagle Mountain specifically, but they pump water up to Jordan Valley Water Conservancy
District and I know Saratoga and Lehigh all have water there too.
But the plan is to connect to that reservoir and then bring this pipeline down all the way
to Airport Road.
And like I said, it was originally cut into three sections and they weren't equal sections
as you can kind of see by the prices, but in the master plan, it was cut into three different
sections.
But again, we're planning to do everything at once.
Is the intent to do that before they start construction on SR-73?
Is that the plan?
Yeah.
It would be nice to kind of be in and out and out of their way.
Yep.
So, Waterline from Sage Valley to Mountain, Mid Valley Road is what that is.
That's actually paralleling our Airport Road that we just put in and it connects onto the
end of the SR-73 pipeline and just takes that south into the city to where more of the development
is so we can get that central Utah down into kind of the heart of the city.
Will that pipe, where will that be placed?
Is that, I know the sewer line kind of runs right underneath the road.
Right.
So when you put the water line in, does that go east-west?
What is that easement?
I'm just curious.
So, we will look at that when we do design.
It will depend on how much right-of-way we have on each side.
And so yeah, that's not determined yet.
That will be determined as part of the design process.
And we try to keep it flexible because there's other utilities around that too.
The airport is right there too.
And that will be a factor that we look at as far as access in and out of there and things
like that.
And so we will look at all of that when we do the full design on it.
Okay.
And then maybe just a general question for me as a new council member.
Funding from these different water projects, are they coming from a specific fee that's
being imposed somewhere for some development?
Or are they coming from it?
Yeah.
The funding for this is all through impact fees.
Okay.
It's due to the growth of the city.
And so every house gets an assessment for that impact fee.
So that $4 million, for example, in this project is being allocated back to the developer.
It is.
On this one, SR73, I guess not the airport pipeline that we're talking about now, but SR73,
we're talking about doing that as part of the bond that we've done also.
And then that bond will be paid back with impact fees.
Okay.
Yep.
One last question.
When they put the sewer line in, it's my understanding that wasn't really -- it was meant to connect
up to the middle school.
Correct.
It's not like a large sewer line, I would imagine, along the airport.
It is.
Oh, it is a large.
Okay.
I think it's a 16-inch, which is -- it's basically a trunk line that will serve that whole
area eventually.
Oh, good.
Okay.
So as development happens along the airport, right?
I just want to make sure we're considering.
Yeah.
All the growth.
Now, as it is right now, that 16-inch actually ties into an 8-inch line, which you never like
to downsize a sewer line like that from a larger to smaller.
Where is that?
That happens right at the south end of Airport Road, and it ties into the Overland subdivision.
And that's a temporary connection.
Okay.
Because one of our other projects we'll talk about today will take that line and continue
it.
Okay.
Thanks.
Just to -- for me understanding, when we run the line up Eagle Mountain Boulevard, it will
be a separate line.
We're not going to be running from that 16-inch line across to the west, is that correct?
For the sewer?
Yeah.
There's a west trunk line that's a little further out in our planning that will pick up everything
on the west side of the city.
Okay.
Yep.
Thanks.
Okay.
The last one, pipeline from Pony Express Parkway to Airport Road.
This one is basically a second phase of the one we just talked about.
It's going to connect on there, and this is water line, not sewer line again.
But we're going to connect on to the water line that we're going to run parallel to Airport
Road and just take it all the way to Pony Express.
And that will give us a good loop in our water system.
In water systems, we love looping, we love redundancy, just so we can shuffle the water where we
need it.
But does this loop that we're going to add, I mean, with the SR 73 and all of that coming
back down to Pony Express Parkway, does that create additional capacity?
I'm assuming it does, to be able to take delivery of more of that acre feet that we have, our contract
with Central Utah Water.
It does, for sure.
Yep.
Will it allow us to take the full capacity of that contract, or is it just a portion?
Yes.
The plan is to design this so that we can get the full capacity of our Central Utah.
Thank you.
Yeah.
It will probably be oversized for now, but in the long term we won't have to replace it.
So, yeah, there's the airport road pipeline and then just a connection over to Pony Express.
Our well 9 is right here east of the airport, and that'll actually connect in to
this.
And so this pipeline will not just be our Central Utah pipeline, but it will connect into
our well system, too.
So we have the redundancy.
Do we have the right of ways and easements for this connection right here?
So we have the piece on the airport already with the church.
All we have is permission to drill on that site, and we've talked to them.
They're master planning their site right now, and they want us to run that pipeline along
their roadways, and they don't know where those roadways are going to be yet.
And so we're in communication with them to be able to do that in the future.
And so as we do the design, we'll take that into account.
Okay.
Jumping to wastewater.
Again, these are all projects.
Oh, yeah.
Go for it.
Okay.
Jumping to wastewater.
Again, these are all projects.
Oh, yeah.
Go for it.
Jumping to wastewater. Again, these are all projects.
Oh, yeah. Go for it.
Okay.
I got a question.
The very last lot.
The well nine.
So, you know that very bottom road that goes north-south, that last lot to the north on the west side.
It looks south from your house, you'll see it.
Okay.
Wastewater projects. These ones are ones we're currently working on, and we're going to continue to ask funding to move forward.
The ox ditch upgrade is really the first phase of our wastewater treatment plant, and it's increasing the capacity of our current process.
The oxidation ditch is really a biological process where we have bacteria that helps take out the chemicals and everything else that's in our wastewater.
And as part of this process, there's going to be a recycling system put in, and we're going to use another one of the existing tanks on site to kind of expand the capacity of what's already there.
And that really just is kind of a band-aid to get us to the timeline that we need to finish the full build-out of the 8 million or the 6 million gallon membrane bioreactor.
Will we continue to use it or utilize its capacity even after the new plant is built?
Okay.
Yep, yep.
And so we'll have two different processes running at the same time, and that's part of the full plan.
There could be a time where we decide to retire that and use that land for something different, but that would be 20-plus years in the future.
Yeah, but I suspect that will happen if we have additional capacity where we can create that affluent water and cease to send it into the ox ditch, right?
Yeah, our master plan, I think, has a full build-out flow capacity of like 14 million gallons, and so this is just our first step to get us up to about 8 million gallons.
And then, yeah, the 6 million gallon MBR wastewater treatment plant.
The membrane bioreactor is newer technology.
You can put it in a smaller space, and the effluent that comes out of it is a much better effluent, better quality, and it's also more usable as far as reuse systems and things like that.
We don't have to have so many tertiary or other treatments that happen after the fact to get it to a point where we can reuse it for watering lawns and gardens and our parks and things like that.
But, yeah, that's going to be a big chunk this year.
That's the estimate of what we will spend just this year.
And then the East Trunk Line at 5.9 million.
So, just to get you oriented on this one, this is Pony Express, kind of coming down, right down the middle here.
This is Airport Road, where it ties into Pony Express.
Now, where we were talking, the end of that 16-inch line is actually right there, right in the corner.
And so, we're going to connect onto that with our East Trunk Line, run it down the rest of Airport Road, and then our East Expressway comes down this way.
And we'll use a lot of that right-of-way where we can.
The elevations don't allow us to use that whole right-of-way.
We'll have to kind of jump down here and go into some of the developments.
We'll obviously keep it in roadways and things like that.
But that trunk line will come down all the way south along that power corridor.
And then we'll jump it to the west over to our treatment plant.
Now, the purpose of this is we have a trunk line right now in Pony Express.
That one, level of service-wise, is about a C at this point, which is at the top end of acceptable.
And so, if we continue to just tie in different developments and commercial or residential developments into that, it's going to be an issue pretty quickly.
And that leaves the groundwork, really, for that Smiths development to come in and to utilize and also for the City Hall area to develop effectively, right?
Correct.
Yep.
So, the green areas in this map are everything that will drain to this east trunk line.
And this actually connects into that airport road, which drains the whole northwest side of the city, eventually, up even by the junior high and across SR73.
That also, as we take that flow that's currently coming down Pony Express and bypass it basically around into our east trunk line, that opens up additional capacity and drops our level of service down from a C back to a B or so and gives us extra capacity in that Pony Express pipeline so we're not right at the top end where we want to be.
And really, most of the stuff in that line, at least, that feeds into that is kind of built out, right?
Probably a little bit of hidden hollow.
Otherwise, that should last us.
It should last us.
Yeah, there are some small areas right around where the Smiths are.
There's kind of some open area there, which will actually go back to Pony Express.
And so, yeah, it should, the plan is to have east trunk line taken off that we don't have to upsize anything in Pony Express to be able to do full build out.
There's a lot of one that goes on the east side that will carry almost that development, right?
Some of it.
Yeah.
Yep, that's right.
Okay.
These are our new projects that we're proposing for this year.
Effluent disposal upgrades as we grow and as we push more water towards the treatment plant.
That just means there's more output from the treatment plant.
And we have to have a way to either reuse or dispose of that.
And so, this one, we're looking at different options for disposal.
We're already kind of talking to some engineers as to what our options could be there.
But this would include full design of that.
But it would also include land acquisition, depending on which option we choose to do.
And really, we're looking at three different options.
We can run a pipeline from the end of our wastewater treatment plant, pump it up to the Tickville wash, and then run it down the Tickville wash.
There's some things that we have to talk to Saratoga Springs about.
Obviously, it flows through them and things we have to consider there.
But that's an option.
The second option would be to get it down to the sinks and then just let it kind of naturally spread.
Right out where the water kind of collected there in the past.
There's wetlands areas down there.
And we would just be increasing the size of those wetlands, obviously.
That would be land acquisition and talking to property owners and things like that to make that happen, too.
Well, you may be getting there.
I was just thinking about the conversation we've had with, is it Mount Airy on their lift station?
I know there's like a process that we're kind of working through, but I'm just wondering if we should account for some budget.
Or we have, was it eight lift stations throughout the city?
Yeah.
So, what's that?
Scenic Mountain.
Scenic Mountain, thank you.
I don't know if we've accounted for those situations or if we should consider that as a council.
It sounds like this is probably the time to be thinking about that.
I've got a different question for you, and it's really, it's a philosophical question where we're looking at dumping money into these disposal upgrades, right?
Are we just limited because the state won't allow us to reuse that water?
Because to me, it seems more pertinent and wiser for us to be putting that money into system upgrades that will accept a secondary water source.
Yes, yes.
And that's absolutely true.
Right now, our disposal is rapid infiltration basins, which are basically big ponds, and we're hoping that the water just goes into the groundwater.
Because we live in a valley that's lined with clay, that happens very slowly, and so we have, we really have an immediate need to expand our capacity.
So, when you're talking about disposal upgrades, are you talking about making some additional ribs?
Is that what I'm hearing you say?
So, that would be an option, too.
Yep.
That would be land acquisition, and that's probably the more expensive and less efficient way to do it because of the clay that we live on.
Now, back to your reuse question, yeah, absolutely, we would love to be able to reuse all the water, and in fact, we've done upgrades to our treatment plant to upgrade the quality of our effluence so that we can reuse it.
But, yeah, it's held up at the state at this point.
We can't get permitted to do that yet.
I get that we have to plan for what our situation is now without that approval, but part of me feels like a one-pager or a fact sheet or something.
Or something could be created with this dollar, this fiscal impact, and the way it would be without being able to use reuse, and the way it would be with reuse, and share that with our partners on the state level that have advocated for that permit for us.
Because how much longer are we going to really spend $10 million because we don't have the reuse permit yet?
That seems really silly.
Not that our staff or anyone's doing it.
It just seems like the state is putting us through an undue burden.
No, but, I mean, you're reading my mind exactly, Council Member Clark, and that's my concern is, at what point are we going, I mean, they want us to be water-wise and efficient.
At what point are they going to help us be that?
Well, and ribs, I mean, you talk about evaporation, like, doesn't water evaporate into the air if we put it in a rib first?
It does.
Yeah, so, like, that's just as bad as, like, watering lawns and stuff like that.
I get that it's after it's treated and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
But we're losing water.
It's totally different than when we can put it back into the system.
Yeah, absolutely on the same page, yeah.
And maybe this is a greater conversation with strategic and legislative affairs, but I totally get what you're saying.
It's like, how much more are we going to burden our taxpayers with the delays that the state's causing?
Well, I mean, this comes from wastewater impact fees.
So the developers are paying for this, and I just think there's a more effective way to put that water to use.
Then we could send that one-page fact sheet to the Home Builders Association and let them also write letters to the state.
I mean, for me, that's all I'm wondering is, isn't there a more efficient way to do this?
And I think the answer is yes, but we're prohibited to do anything effective about it today, and we need to deal with it.
I'm sure you've thought about this, Vince.
Have you thought about anything outside of the box that's different than this?
Is there something else that we can do in the hope that this is a temporary problem, not a permanent solution that we have to come up with?
Right, right, and I think that would be the RIB solution just to expand the capacity we have to store by site.
Can we build bigger berms on our RIBs and just funnel it all down there and just take longer to percolate?
I mean, I don't know the answer.
I'm not a water guy.
Right.
But the more I learn about this, the more I realize that there's a lot that we can be doing that we're not doing.
So the most logical step would be not to do RIBs or to put the water into a particular wash, because both will evaporate.
And the reason that the state is not overly excited about reuse is because the reuse is used in the secondary system for which it would evaporate when you put it in people's yards and whatnot.
So short of using it for other uses that we're trying to figure out and come together with, another alternative might be to increase the water quality even one step further, which makes it culinary grade, and then direct inject that into the aquifer itself.
You can't direct inject if it's a type 2, type 1 water, you still have to make it culinary grade, but by direct inject, you don't have the evaporation and at least would improve our aquifer.
Have we considered the cost differential?
Because I'm going to tell you, if we're sitting here looking at $7 million, would that money, that's the question in my mind, would that money be better spent in investing in a system that would allow us to do something that's more effective with that water?
So what we have to do in order to have the project go forward is we have to have the ability to say in our plan what we're going to use as the water, where the water will go.
And the state is the one that's really pushing us away from the RABs, which are not effective because of our clay layer, to the tickle wash.
We do have grave concern that when you put that water into the tickle wash, we'll be changing the environmental nature of that wash, thereby greening it up, adding the potential for endangered species or whatever we might be doing.
Once we change the environment and we start adding water to that, then getting water away from that could be a negative impact as well.
And so time is of the essence, and that's why we're meeting with the state engineer's office and the Department of Water Quality, because we would much rather reuse the water in an appropriate method.
But yet our plan still has to have a way to get rid of the sewer fluid, and if we don't, we don't get the permit, and we can't process our sewer.
So we have to jump through the hoops, and we're following their direction at this point, but we are working concurrently to try to change the politics of it as well.
But if that changes, then we would not spend this money, correct?
It's all the timing and the approvals and whatnot, but yes, that's our goal.
So I mean, I would say put it in a tick to a wash, at least threaten that, because something that I wanted everyone here to know, especially on this end, these guys I think were in those conversations, but I met with Sandal Saturday, and he's kind of the water guy up at the state.
I told him right now our stuff's just evaporating currently, and he's like, what are you talking about?
And I said, you know, we can get this to the lake much quicker, and so now he's also on board, and I think that we, I mean, I wouldn't be in favor.
We need to have a plan, but I definitely wouldn't pull the trigger on that, knowing that we just need to keep pressuring them.
What is the timeline, Vince, where we're going to be compelled to have to do something with this additional water discharge?
So the initial study would take probably three to six months, depending on the option that we choose, and then after that, it would be property acquisition if we decide to go that way, and I think at that point, that's where we're really saying this is absolutely where we're going to go with it if we start buying property.
And so four to six months, I said, I would say is where we have some flexibility.
Mayor, I hope you can get in front of the state and go advocate.
I know you've been doing that, but I'm hopeful that maybe we can get something to change where we might be able to pursue a different course of action.
But they're not in session, so even if we...
I mean, I guess they could approve the permit, right?
Yes.
So, and that's where it really comes out.
We have to get the sewer processing permit approved, and you can't get the permit approved without saying how you're going to use the water, even though we might be working on another way to dispose of the water.
So are you suggesting, Ben, the best way to approach it is to approve this in the budget so that it recognizes that there is a plan to take care of it, but then to go to the powers that be and say, help us do something better?
Absolutely, and the reason being is we can do exactly what Councilmember Clark just mentioned a few minutes ago, which is we now have a story to share of money that's wasted with our state legislators.
Okay, that's perfect.
I like that.
But not waste it, right?
I don't like the wasted money, but I like the plan.
Yes, yes, that we want to invest the money properly so that we can truly reuse that water and create a return on it and have an ever-growing water resource as our sewer processing continues to grow, as our community continues to grow.
Yep.
So, Councilmember Wright, your idea of having other options, the next project is really kind of another option and another step.
I did, yep.
So, this tertiary treatment phase two, reverse osmosis, is the one that, reverse osmosis really takes the salinity of our effluent and bumps that number way down.
Because that's the number that really is preventing us from just injecting it right back into our aquifer.
If we inject high salinity water into the aquifer, eventually it will infiltrate and we'll be getting high salinity water into our wells, and we just, we want to avoid that.
And so, in order to make that process happen, we have to have a reverse osmosis piece added to, it's another treatment train that would be added to our existing train that we already do at the wastewater treatment site.
Now, if we decide to not do direct injection and go with a different effluent, this would not be a wasted study or a wasted number, because this is also the next step to be able to make our effluent better for watering our parks and our yards and things like that.
And it's really the next step in direct potable reuse also, which years down the road, we may have to go to that.
Just for clarification, the 300,000 that's listed under the tertiary treatment phase two reverse osmosis, is that to implement it or to study it?
It is not.
Nope.
That's just an initial study in engineering design to figure out how we could fit that onto our existing train.
I just feel like I got the wrong degree at college.
Okay.
Steeplechase lift station upgrade.
This is one.
The steeplechase lift station is basically the lift station that's down by Mehta.
It's clear on the south end of the city, which is not too far from our wastewater treatment plant, but it's downhill enough that we can't get gravity flow into our current wastewater treatment plant.
And so there is an existing lift station there right now.
And this would, with Mehta's expansion and with Williams going in down there, it's just a study and a design to determine what needs to happen to be able to take care of their effluent.
Now, on their end, they're working with SOMAS engineering to kind of look at what their future demands are going to be on that lift station.
And so we'll be working closely with them on that project to determine what that upgrade is going to look like.
But it's more than likely upgrade of pumps, upgrade of electrical systems, things like that.
I am just wondering if the city will be able to capture the cost of this study and any potential upgrades in the fees for this one particular user.
Yeah, that's a good question.
I don't know, Kimberly, if you had a thought on that.
I missed the very beginning part of that.
Okay, so you're fine, Kimberly.
I know you're pulling stuff together.
It's the steeplechase lift station upgrade.
And what I'm asking is, will the city be able to capture this cost and any cost for any additional upgrades from this one additional user or this one user with fees?
This is the one where the city is going to, just looking at, basically, it's been a private lift station and now the city is going to be.
No, this is the one that's over by Meta.
This is the city lift station, yeah.
It's down by Meta.
Yeah, so in terms of, we haven't had, how about I just, there hasn't been any conversation about that at this point.
Do we have the ability to recoup fees?
Yes.
But only if you start breaking out your rates into certain fee areas, depending on the users that are in there.
And we wouldn't be able to just single out, well, we just want this one lift station and we're going to assess only them.
Any other lift station that then the city has, we would need to make sure that we're looking at that regionally and then you're choosing to break those rates up.
Even for the data center?
When it's very specifically for the data center?
There are, well, we could look into a little bit further, but there are certain terms in their agreements about our rates that say specifically that we can't do things that target this type of industry specifically.
And Marcus might not, but that was what, when I had done my research that they had had some information that was like, we can do rates, but we can't make rate changes that are targeted only for data centers.
So we'd have to do a rate change that's relevant to the industrial users of the city, or you could say for lift stations, we want to have everybody who is being serviced by a lift station that we're going to start assessing a lift station fee as part of their wastewater billings.
I would like for us as a city to look at ways to capture those funds back because we've had great robust discussions as a body about whether or not we're willing to take on a lift station responsibility for 120 homeowners.
But we can't ask for those funds to be included.
There's got to be something in the development agreement or something else.
I just don't see us subsidizing a business with dollar amounts when they're the only ones using that lift station.
I think that's really the question is, does the development agreement require them to pay for this?
And if it doesn't, then my next question would simply be this.
As we look at any future expansion or any other requests that they bring, I think we need to be conscientious of these things and make sure that it's contained in a new amendment to a development agreement.
I agree with Council Member Clark.
There's no reason for the citizen to bear the burden of increasing, of studying and paying for an upgrade to a sewer lift station that services one company.
I just, I think fundamentally that's wrong.
Now they may have paid wastewater impact fees of which we would be able to utilize impact fee funds to be able to do an upgrade if it's increasing capacity that is for that purpose.
Those would be the funds that they would have already paid that we would be able to utilize.
They would have paid the impact fee funds?
So if, what the original agreement was, so if this is the original data centers, there are certain fees that, anyway, I don't know if we collected them all up front or not, but if there were impact fees that were paid, regardless if it's them, right, if it's a system upgrade, then, and the lift stations are there, and it's enhancing it, we would be able to use impact fees for that only if it's increasing capacity to the lift station.
Well, Mayor, maybe as a council, and I don't know if the council supports us or not, maybe we could just ask you to bring us the, to have someone research and bring us the data that helps us understand the impacts that we're dealing with here.
What's the history?
What's the historical context?
It would just be good to review it, because, frankly, if we didn't consider this, as we took a look at the Williams approval, then we missed it, and I think we need to learn from that mistake.
So, it sounds like a couple of things need to happen.
I'm going to need some help from Marcus to review the contract and Vince to help us understand that.
So, do you guys want to put something together that, and anyone else that might?
Yeah, I'm not as familiar as what this upgrade is intended to accomplish, so it's hard to say.
If it is to facilitate the expansion for meta, then that is something that is baked into the development agreement for us to meet and confer and assess, you know,
what portion they need to pay for things like that.
If it's for existing for some reason, then that will be governed separately.
But if it's for the expansion, then this is something that is baked into the agreement, because all of the infrastructure upgrades at the time we did that development agreement were not known.
And so, we put in a provision that we'd come back and look at what they need to do.
That's the same data I'm looking for, Marcus.
That is something that was considered when we did the development agreement.
So, it sounds like this could be something that they should have to pay for anyway.
So, we need to get...
I would certainly think that if it is only being done because of their expansion, then yes.
So, before we fund this, we need to make sure that we get that information and bring it back, if that's okay.
And as Kimberly alluded to, there's multiple ways to fund it.
It could be they just pay for it directly.
It could be they pay impact fees that pays for it.
There's various methods of accomplishing the same goal.
As long as we make sure.
Yeah, but the goal is that, hey, if it's for the...
If it's being necessitated by their expansion, then they should pay for it.
So, if you get that back to us.
We got another budget meeting coming in a couple weeks, I presume.
So, just stay on top of that.
If you would.
Sounds good.
Okay.
So, the last project on the list here is our effluent pond storage liner replacement.
We just talked about RIBs where we're trying to get rid of water and get water to go into the ground.
We have two ponds out there that are currently our return water from Metta that we actually do use in our secondary system.
And that water, we do want to save as much of it as we can.
And so, we have two ponds that are lined.
Those liners over the years have worn.
And with weather and storms and things that have come through, they've ripped up pretty good.
And so, we're at a point where we need to replace those liners.
They're beyond their useful life.
And so, that will be the $4 million.
So, any questions on that one?
I do have one question on all of these.
Is there a reason?
Are these just like good round numbers?
I get a little worried when I just see round numbers like give or take a million.
Right.
How close are we to the actual cost?
Is it going to be my question?
These are probably within...
Like, what's the standard deviation of where we're going to actually land?
Probably 25%.
Oh, okay.
Yep.
Or within 25%.
Until we get into the actual RFP process.
I think it's important to understand that this is our staff saying, hey, these are the things.
And this is what we think it could cost.
But we have not gone to bid.
We don't have a design.
So, he's trying to let us, when he says 25%, obviously, we could bid it and be higher or lower.
And that's more my question.
So, my question, like, are we budgeting over 25%?
So, our intent, and these numbers do have contingencies in them for the most part.
And so, the hope is that this is the high end and it will come down.
It doesn't always end up that way, but that's our hope.
I'm going to hold you to it.
No, I'm just kidding.
Thank you.
And what it does for us on the finance side is we're looking at our reserves and where we're at, and then we start committing.
Right?
We're saying this much is being killed off and we have to commit it for this project because we're starting it and moving forward to make sure that we will have the cash flow and the funds available at the time when that project comes forward.
And any funds not used stay in the capital project fund for future projects?
I think that's it for me.
Oh, stormwater is the next one.
In our stormwater request for this year, we only have one project, and this is a project that was in our last stormwater master plan that we did in 2000, I think it was 2020 when we did that plan.
What this is, is bank reinforcement.
There's areas in that plan where it shows that weathering of the bank, which is a natural process, but it's getting close to people's backyards and structures and things like that.
And so the plan is to go in and reinforce those banks with either large riprap or gabion baskets, which are kind of the wired baskets that are rock-filled to keep those banks in place and to protect property from damage.
Because we don't have a biologist on staff or an environmental planner on staff currently, is there going to be some sort of review to make sure that we're not destroying critical habitat and shoring up the issues that we're concerned about?
Yeah, that will be part of the design process.
As we get into the design, we'll hire an engineer out, and they will look at that as part of the process.
Okay, thank you.
I'm curious if any of this has been done over in the Silver Lake area already.
I mean, Field's a flagship.
Flagship did a lot of work down in there already.
Yes.
And I know they had to work with the Army Corps of Engineers to get a permit, and it was very specific.
Is this something that we're coming in and repairing that they did, or is it something that they didn't do that they should have done?
Northridge.
The one on the right side is Silver Lake.
Yeah, so there's kind of two different areas.
And, yeah, go ahead.
This does not include any of the work that Flagship did.
This is, when you're looking at the Silver Lake area, this is more specific to the Silver Lake Village side.
That has some serious erosion where the homes are pretty close.
And when it comes to the wash, right, we don't want a straight wash that shoots through.
But in some of these areas, the wash has gone completely the other direction, and it kind of ping-pongs back and forth, right?
And when it ping-pongs, that's where it makes these cuts to the wall.
I don't take any issue with the need to do it.
My concern really was, are we repairing something that wasn't done correctly, and it doesn't sound like that's the case.
We've already done some BDA work and gabing basket work upstream of where they did their work.
And this is work that needs to take place downstream.
And some of that is trying to place BDAs so that we can slow the water down and try to actually utilize more of the wash, right?
Some of this wash is incredibly wide, but when you get down to the ditch, right, it's four or five feet wide.
And so we want to try to spread some of that and straighten it just a little bit so it meanders instead of ping-pongs.
And then we need things like gabing baskets and stuff just to shore it up.
And frankly, Zach, I mean, you're raising a point that was concerning to me when we were talking about the wastewater.
If we're going to dump that affluent into the Tickbill Gulf, we're only going to have these types of mitigation problems that we're going to have to deal with regularly.
So it's not free to do that.
Yeah.
Okay.
Just a quick question before you walk away.
Did we fix the wash wall where we had the water main leak off of Silver Creek shot through between the houses?
Yes.
So we've already solved that wash wall?
Yeah.
I believe that's – I believe so.
I guess I can't say 100%, but I believe that was all done.
Yeah, because I know that was compromised as a result of that.
Yeah, which isn't part of this.
This is more of –
Right.
While we're there, though, let's make sure that that part has been eroded.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
Just going back to something you said earlier, you said the church is master planning the area north of Lone Tree.
Yep.
And I'm just curious, is this the first time we're hearing this as a council?
Yes.
And the reason why I say that is landowners really should come to the council and be a little bit more collaborative, in my opinion.
And so if they want a master plan, we're not – apparently we're not being involved in that thought process.
And I would really prefer landowners and developers to come to us first, and then we can start to have a collaborative discussion from the beginning,
instead of them deciding what they're going to do, say, well, this is what we're going to do, and then come to us.
Now, we want them to come to us early in the process.
So I get a little frustrated when they're off planning something and they haven't even talked to us.
And so I don't know how we remedy that, but if – I mean, I would assume the council would agree with me on this issue.
Well, I think the answer is developers have found if they don't collaborate, they get a very quick no.
So I think that's what's there.
This is one that I've mentioned to the body that would be coming and that I was nervous on our general plan that if we left as agricultural,
it might leave an unknown what is it that we really want.
So I've mentioned that I knew they were working on it, but nobody's seen anything.
And really, if they don't come to us, that's their fault if they're going to know.
How do we know they're working on it then?
Nobody's seen it.
What was the question?
Well, that's – he brought it to us before, and he's like, oh, we need to leave it as agriculture.
But, I mean, somebody's seen something.
We know that something is happening.
Why don't we just bring it to us and say, let's talk about it?
Because it's not a small piece of property.
It's huge.
And it's going to have an absolute impact on everything around it, depending on how they decide to develop it.
So I just – with the very likelihood of creating schools from it, that's how big it is.
So I just – I agree with Craig.
I think we need to push them to bring it in.
I don't care what stage they're at.
Let's have a chat.
Have them come forward in a work session or have them meet with two or three of the mayor and two council members, I think, honestly.
Is this all the way from Lone Tree up to Sage Valley?
Yes.
That's all their property.
Well, I know they own all of that, but the part that's being considered –
That's the master plan is the whole property.
Okay.
Yeah.
The zoning all around that is –
And, again, I want to reiterate, I don't think anybody knows what they're planning.
It's only been said to the planning commission – sorry, not planning commission – the planning staff that, hey, by the way, we're looking at this area.
That means nothing.
And so there is no stage of development.
What it is is we know that in their mind they're thinking about something.
If they don't collaborate, then they're going to get likely known.
I don't think they're as far along as you might think they are.
It's up to them.
You know, I mean, I'm not calling everybody saying, hey, by the way, can you come to work session, tell us what you're doing?
It's up to them to initiate the call.
So maybe we need to train the planning staff, because they're probably sort of at the tip of the spear, is my guess,
that if they're hearing stuff like this, that their trained response to these developers would be, hey, have you talked to the city council members yet?
Have you sort of floated by them what you're wanting to do?
Have you met with them to see what the city's looking for?
Maybe have them sort of plant that bug in the ears of the landowners?
And my guess is that is what happens, and they're just not quite there, meaning they're in the very preliminary stages of discussion, but that is how we treat it, is my belief.
So why would we be concerned about the agriculture, then?
If they're not very far down the road, why would we even have a concern about agriculture?
I just exploded out there as my own personal belief that I think with no direction, there's no direction.
And I wanted to indicate exactly that my belief is it should be bigger lots.
That way they know what it is that we're looking for up front as they come forward.
If you think that agriculture is fine, then I think that's a fight we're going to have to fight.
I'm just going to go one step further.
I think what Craig's saying is we need to reach out to the church and say we'd like to talk about this parcel.
I mean, the reality is I think that's where we're at.
It's too big to wait for them to come to their own conclusions, work with other entities, school district as an example of that,
and make decisions that we're not even, haven't been apprised to, and then we have to live with that decision.
Nobody's made a decision.
That's my whole point.
The church, nobody.
There's no decision in every decision.
Jared, I'm not saying that.
I'm saying we reach out to the representatives from the church and say we'd like to talk about your piece of property here.
Yeah.
I can certainly do that.
We actually met with the church today, this afternoon, and had a meeting about other properties,
but that's the first I had heard that they were designing, that they were starting to master plan.
We'll reach back out to them and request a meeting, or at least request either a work session or request some individual meetings.
It might be even easier in a private, like a, not that we're trying to keep something out of the public,
but like just the mayor and two council members, because that's easier to brainstorm outside the public eye.
I volunteer as tribute.
Thank you for that meeting.
Okay.
And that's all I had.
I'll turn it over to Mr. Hilton to do the rest.
Okay, just real quick.
Can we just thank, can we just thank Ben for proactive?
Thank you.
Great work.
And before we go on, I probably should have done this earlier, but I just hadn't put into motion because I didn't know what it was going to fit.
But I meant to mention Zach's birthday today, and our awesome staff brought birthday cake, but I didn't tell everybody to grab one, so Natalie's been over there cutting that for us.
And I'm not a singer, but I know we've got a hard stop in one hour, so I just asked her to cut it, and as we go on, maybe bring a piece up to each one of the council members and the staff, and we'll say happy birthday to Zach.
So that's why that's over there.
Thank you, Mayor, and thank you, everyone, whoever prepared that.
We do not need to sing.
We can roll on with parks, have a piece of cake, and continue.
Thank you.
If you want to bring those up, and we'll just, maybe if we keep our mouths full, we'll likely get through a little bit more.
Yeah, I was just going to say good timing, Mayor.
Thanks.
I'd prefer to do mine while you guys are all eating.
So, good evening.
Good afternoon, Council and Mayor.
I'm going to do the parks portion of these projects.
I'm going to start with the list of projects that we are currently in, in several different stages, and I want to talk about some of these, just most of these projects will need to roll over into the next budget year.
The first one is the trail from Pony Express Parkway to SR73, which is a MAG project that we're receiving funding for.
This project goes from Pony Express, basically where the park and ride is located at, and we'll go up and tie in by 73 up by the Scenic Mountain subdivision.
So, we are being held up on funding for this project, it is approved, but they use some of the money that was originally meant to go to this, some federal funding, so they're reallocating some money.
So, we're just waiting for the approval on that to move forward.
Zach, can I just jump in really quick?
I do want to just clarify on that, you're not one with the ranches trail and stuff.
So, that is the estimated cost of the project, but the city's cost will, it's only around 6% or something.
Yeah, that we will have to make on that, and we have that portion allocated, I can pull it up, but that is the full estimated project cost.
The second one is the observatory, which is, we're still trying to receive more donations for.
I do know that staff recently just did a presentation to the county, and I understand that Metta is possibly looking at doing some extra donations.
I just was going to ask, have we reached out to QTS?
They're looking for some opportunities to do something in the community, this might be something they're looking for.
I do not know.
I mean, I know when they very first came, that was one of their objectives, to not just come build the data center, but to actively invest in the community.
This might be a good opportunity as a kickoff for them.
Yeah, I don't know that.
So, I think where Metta started off in this project, and we're working through the county to try to acquire grant funds right now, we're looking to Metta to
finish off this project, and maybe other opportunities for QTS, since this one's kind of there.
The third is the Eagle Monument, which is well on its way.
Eagle Mountain staff has already been out there and rebuilt the retaining wall.
The contractor has been out there, has poured the footings and the pad.
Right now, the schedule date is to have this installed around the end of May.
So, this is one project we should be able to complete without rolling over to the next year.
Well, I'll cue it in just real quick.
I'll throw out the original estimate was between $40,000 and maybe $50,000.
Is this an additional $80,000 or an additional $30,000 or what's the...
No, the approved amount is $80,000.
This is what's approved, and it's going to be pretty close to this.
Including the budget amendment from before?
Because we didn't...
No, we never actually allocated or approved any money until the last budget amendment.
And that's when we allocated the $80,000.
And that was based off of design that was approved and cost.
As well as the retaining wall.
So, maybe...
Yes, yes.
That's the sign versus the wall that we did there.
Yeah, there's...
We had to rebuild the retaining wall.
So, it feels like we approved this twice is what I'm getting at.
Didn't we already approve this in a budget amendment?
It's already out.
All these projects that I'm going over right now are already funded projects.
It's just that a good portion of these are going to need to roll over into the 27 year.
This one is one we should be able to complete, right?
But most of these projects will need to roll over.
I think the confusion is because we just have that one header at the top that says additional budget requested.
These projects are already allocated.
Yes, yep.
There's funding for all these ones that I'm going over first.
Zach, timing on the parking lot expansion at Cory Ride?
So, we have...
Well...
We have designed for the parking lot right now.
The goal is to have a contractor and be building that hopefully this summer.
This is a project that will certainly be rolled over into the next year, but we want to start construction on it this season.
I'm just wondering, with some of the big events like 4th of July and some of the bigger ones, obviously not Pony Express days, but will we be able to accommodate more people?
And that's why I was asking about the time, so...
The parking lot won't be finished for those.
It will probably be more likely that we'll have to coordinate with contractors on blackout dates, that they're not allowed to work.
And the one before that is actually the festival-filled lights, which is also a quarry ride.
We were really trying to have these done for the events this year.
It's still a maybe, but not likely.
We're just waiting on materials to have them in place.
This one will likely still be done before the end of the budget season, but unfortunately we probably won't have it for the Pony Express days events.
The last one on this page is the digital sign, which was approved at the budget amendment as well on the last budget amendment.
This one, staff will work with the contractor to come up with what we think is the appropriate design.
And this one will still come back to Council for approval, because I think there still needs to be discussion about the size of the digital sign.
Next, we have the cemetery master plan, which we haven't started on yet.
This year we took an ambitious goal of doing all master plans.
And so this is just the last one that we need to get going on.
So this one will also be one that we'll roll over into the 27.
The next one is the city center streetscapes.
This is funding that was from the utility cells.
And we've pushed this for quite a few years due to construction.
A ton of utilities.
There's two fiber lines going down that road right now.
I think you should ask that question.
The question I just leaned over now, Council Member Clark, is there even still a need to do it?
We're getting ready to rip these out.
So to clarify, there are two.
The city center streetscapes is the side of the street.
There is another $500,000 allocated for the medians, which is a different discussion that we do not.
The medians we should do, the medians we should just draft that as well.
Absolutely agree.
And that's not on that list for that reason.
The streetscape side, which is the shoulder, I think it's time we need to consider doing a bunch of that,
especially where we have moved the parade route this year.
I think that means in this next year, we really need to hash out what that's going to look like and try to get that done.
I think to your point, this is always a moving target.
For instance, the new approval with the commercial project is going to widen that to three lanes.
And so, even on the shoulders, I was looking for David because I think a lot of Pawnee Express could be...
He took off.
I know he had to leave.
But what I would say is this.
I mean, my suggestion would be we definitely should focus on those city center streetscapes.
I agree with that 100%.
And if we need to pull some of the budget out of those medians, if we need to take that $500,000 and dedicate it to doing more of the city center...
And that may be that...
I absolutely would be in favor of that.
So, I don't know how everyone else is going to feel about that, but I think we ought to do what we can to doll those things up real quick.
And answer, I guess, some of your comment, Mayor.
It's obviously something we would work closely with David to, so that we're not just putting it in and tearing it out.
Next is the Mountain Ranch Bike Park Edition.
That will...
This will need to roll over as well.
But the intent on this one is to go out for design.
This would be specifically targeting the parcel that we have between Golden Eagle and Ranches Parkway that is underneath the power line corridor to provide, like, the intent is to do, like, some parking, provide a parking spot and do maybe some more, like, beginner-level pump track type of stuff.
And then, lastly, for current projects, we have the Nolan Park improvements where we have money allocated to make some improvements to Nolan Park.
You know, we've had a number of people come in and ask about improving this.
It could very well.
I think some of the intent is to focus around the splash pad as well, because the splash pad is a non-recycling amenity.
That water pretty much is just wasted where our other one is recycled.
So, I'm going to loop it, then.
Okay.
So...
And that...
This is just for design and plan?
There's not actually anything that's happening with the 750?
No.
There's enough there that that would have construction with it, too.
I would assume probably not enough.
It just depends on what the design is, right?
Okay.
Thank you.
In fact, this might be the wrong time, but I'm just going to plant this seed.
I really would like to have a discussion as a council regarding parks, and what are the...
I mean, what are the next targeted...
And you guys probably already know this, and I should know this.
What are the next targeted big community or...
I always forget the terminology that you use.
Yeah, the region or the community-sized parks that we're targeting for improvement with impact fees.
I don't want to have that conversation right now, because I don't know that this is the appropriate time.
But I think it would be nice to say...
To understand what the planning is, where we're trying to program.
This park is next, and this one's next on the list, and this one's next on the list.
I think my next slide will hit that a little bit for you.
Look, you anticipated it.
Good work.
That brings us to some of our requests for the 27 budget.
That we would like to have $150,000 for the Pony Express Regional Park.
To do a design for the Pony Express Park, as well as $150,000 for the Silver Lake Community Park.
Which is in...
It's in Silver Lake.
There's already a portion.
I don't know.
It's right there by Tickville Wash that kind of includes that L-shape that we could complete that park.
We're talking about east of the amphitheater, correct?
For Silver Lake.
This is like...
No, it's south of the amphitheater.
It's down by Tickville Wash, right off of Silver Lake.
I think the road that ties into it is called Silver Parkway.
Is this the Woodhaven Park, or is this right?
Yeah, it's...
I think this is the Woodhaven one, right?
On the east by the elementary school, north of the Wash?
It's north, yes.
North of the elementary school.
It's right on the north side of Tickville Wash, yes.
We have two detention ponds right in the undeveloped area and everything.
It kind of makes it an L-shape to complete that park.
Do we have a plan to complete the Silver Lake Amphitheater Park?
No.
We already had that park designed.
Like, we paid for it, and there was a Phase B as part of that.
Is that not attainable anymore?
Couldn't we just use what was done?
I'd have to look into that.
Colby, Curtis, and I were both on the steering committee for that,
and I know that we asked them to program that in
because it was supposed to be a part of regional connectivity
with the trails along Tickville Wash, too,
and that was all part of the design.
I'll have to look into that.
Okay.
And lastly is the property acquisition,
which is actually not an expenditure for the next year,
but it's just allocating those funds.
We did an additional $1 million last year
with the intent that in 2028
that we have the $3 million to actually go out and acquire land
to do some improvements on some of our bigger parks.
We've kind of focused on this $3 million in 2028
with the mindset of doing another quad for baseball.
So I'm still concerned about, and I know we've talked about this briefly in the past,
but the areas in city center where there's all those undeveloped open space areas,
and it seems like we've got to get that on the plan somewhere
because it seems to me like there's still no plan, right?
And how long is there going to be no plan for those areas?
I think that goes to Council Member Wright's point
about having a discussion about what's the next thing
that we're going to do and what we're going to prioritize
because I feel like the list that we have right here
are all the things that we decided already to program
and that they were approved way prior to this
and that they're cleaning those things up and wrapping those up
and now it's on us to have a meeting specifically
about programming and planning the rest of it.
And I know it's just another plan,
but to me, you know, in the next council meeting,
we'll be bringing back our parks, trails, and open space master plan
that played kind of the first role in that,
and identifying our open space
and identifying what is undeveloped
because that's really what you're referring to
is the undeveloped areas and what we do with those.
But that master plan is a bit of a higher level.
And I think to me, the next step is identifying those undeveloped areas
and having an additional plan of what identifies those, right?
What are key components in those that are they things we want to develop?
What do they look like?
Are they land disposal?
Are they a hybrid of both, right?
We've done those even.
But to me, I think that's the next step after the parks, trails,
and open space master plan is actually having a plan specific to the undeveloped.
I feel like we need to have three separate meetings.
One, that we talk about trails.
That needs to be a comprehensive discussion about what we want our trails to be.
We probably need to treat it the same way that we treat our roads,
have level of trails with cutouts of exactly what that's going to look like.
So it's going to be an eight-foot or it's going to be a ten-foot.
It's going to be asphalt and it's going to have this on either side of it.
When we go to the next level of trail, it'll be this.
And then we need to do the same thing with our parks.
We need to literally bring in our regional parks and go through each of those steps and say,
okay, what is our plan with this?
What kind of funding mechanisms do we need to put in place?
So we're, to Craig's point, we're not just kicking them down the road.
And then we need to have one that's about the land that we own that is open space that is not improved
and have a discussion about how we're going to move forward with it.
Are we going to do something with it?
Are we going to sit on it for a while?
Or do we need to dispose of this property with a plan of disposal that makes it beneficial to the community?
But I think there's not enough time to have all three of those discussions in one meeting.
They need to be separated and then we need to have a discussion about a financial plan to deal with those things, in my opinion.
I actually support doing it that way.
I think sometimes we try to fit too much into a meeting and Councilmember Rowan, I think that's a perfect plan.
You're not, just to clarify, you're not referring to the master plan that's coming back.
I'm talking about the funding mechanism to take care of all three of those things.
Then your master plan actually makes sense because we have a plan in place to move forward with what that is.
And yes, there's going to be some additional elements to that that aren't in the master plan,
especially if we're doing cutaways of trails.
You know what section I'm talking about in the streets where it shows kind of the,
if I'm looking down the road for a major collector, minor collector, arterial,
this is the width of each of the roads.
It'll have a median or not have a median.
This is how much curb and gutter, here's the sidewalk and here's what's on the side.
I think we need to get to that level with our trails so that it's very clear.
And then our map needs to represent, when we're looking at it by color, it's an eight-foot asphalt path.
This is the main vein that everything else will come off of
and the next level will be a smaller level of trail system.
Maybe it's just dirt.
But that way it's at least clear to us how we're maintaining them
and where we need to be spending our focus of time and money on.
I personally struggle when I see that we've got $3 million allocated for purchase
when we have so much land that we could spend that $3 million on developing what we already have.
So just to be clear real quick too, that is impact fee money.
So it's not like we can take that money to go just develop any, it looks like Kimberly's.
And I think when you're talking too about the plan and what you're missing a little bit
is we currently have the Parks and Trails Impact Fee Facilities Plan, right?
So I believe that the first phase was working on the Master Plan.
Is that kind of how they work?
You do your Master Plan.
Then from your Master Plan, you move into the Impact Fee Facilities Plan
and then you move into the Impact Fee IFA, which is our funding source.
So I believe all that is tracking forward, but I think what it is
is that we've got to get through the Master Plan in order to move to the next phase,
which starts to get more granular.
So that Master Plan is that higher level.
Then we're going to get the IFFP that's going to get more granular.
And then from there, it converts to how much is this going to cost
and we have this funding mechanism that comes into place for the Impact Fee
and what we're going to try to spend.
Yeah, and there's going to be some restrictions on what you can spend
in the Impact Fee for parks, too, based off of acreage.
So I think this is a good opportunity to just plant this seed.
We can look at every single detail of every trail,
but one of the reasons some of our citizen boards haven't worked in the past
and I've sat on almost every one of them
is because they don't have a specific task.
I think this is one of those areas that specifically we could task with the Community Services Board
to do most of what you're talking about first and then get in.
And I agree the funding part is probably the next step.
But I think the first task that we as a body would want to say,
you know, I want the direction to come from the body is,
hey, go identify.
And I know Zach and I, even on Facebook, had some conversation.
Identify all of our parks.
Prioritize which ones are the most important.
Our trails, which ones are the most impactful, you know, in order.
And then we can start chipping away some funding.
But to me, that whole process, before we even start having multiple meetings,
is let's empower that board to locate every single park and trail,
prioritize each one, and then come to us with an idea
and then we can start allocating money as it comes in.
And expand on that idea if you wish.
But I would say that's where we could start
and just empower them to do that
before we go even another step forward on what you're saying is the plan, right?
Is that just the idea that I've had with the board?
I think Steve and I have talked and Zach and I for sure.
Is that what you guys want to do or a different direction?
I think you have to have instruction first for them to be able to act on.
So I think the community services board is exactly who should be doing it,
but we need to give them clear direction on what to do.
And they can bring that information back to us
and we can move forward with that.
But I think the master plan is only as good as your ability
to understand what it is and what its purpose is.
If it's just to show us what we have, it's not really a plan.
It's a map.
And I think that we need to have something in place
to set a financial plan in that master plan
of how we're going to move through each of those trails, parks,
starting from regional parks being the most important that we've identified.
But there's a lot of parks that we have half finished that need to be finished.
As part of that, we also need to talk about the paths that run along the right-of-ways
that we haven't completed.
So, I mean, there's some broader discussions,
but you can't eat the whole elephant at one time.
So, it's better to break it apart and say,
this discussion is going to be about parks.
This discussion is going to be about our open space.
This one's going to be about our trails.
We can give instruction at that point for the community services
to gather the information, bring their ideas back,
and then we can move on to those things.
Okay.
I agree.
I think we're meeting with the community services board tomorrow.
We've got a lot to get incepted and get everything rolling,
but that's certainly a task they can take on.
I commented on Facebook that we have our own asphalt machine,
and it's like having a baby grand piano, but you never play it.
I want to name that thing baby grand, and I want to see it going 365.
So, just to touch on that, right?
Well, and this is, because we do do a lot of projects,
and we do use our paver a lot,
but this is also the streets department does the paving.
So, when we're committing to doing trailways and parking lots
and things like that, being aware that we're using up a department
that has their own duties that's budgeted for something else, right?
It isn't like anyone can just put jump on a paver.
For employees, that's what it sounds like.
They're building a trailhead right now, right,
which is grant money that we received,
that basically we're building a parking lot and parking areas
and a turnaround that's pavement and concrete,
but it's the streets department building it.
And we use these a lot in places where we receive funding
just so that we can maximize that money instead of bidding it out.
Those are one of the ones we really like to do in-house.
So, we can maximize those free dollars.
And just to clarify, in your presentation,
the projects that you're putting forward,
those are coming from the general fund,
you're not anticipating any wrap tax dollars for these projects?
No, not on these.
Okay.
I just want to clarify.
No.
And I would just add one thing as far as when we talk about adding these trails
and things like that, just a friendly reminder,
and I know we talked about it a little bit,
is just remembering that it's,
when we develop these areas and we add trails and we add things like this,
it's a two-fold expenditure, right?
It could cost money.
We can't just go out and build them and then cheer and walk away.
Like, we need to be prepared to have a level of service that costs money to maintain those too,
whether it's trees or it's trails or it's undeveloped open space.
These are all things we have to,
if we're going to build them,
we have to commit to maintaining them.
So, agreed.
Just for a little clarity, Zach,
you said 365 paving can only happen early in the summer.
It has a certain temperature.
We're double-timing in the summer.
Okay.
Fair enough.
Ground the clock in.
But that's, it does get,
that thing gets used.
It does.
And like I say, just a reminder, right?
It is a whole different department that's capable of doing that,
that we have to be prepared to take away from them doing maintenance on roadways.
So, yep.
And then just to wrap,
I wanted to make sure,
and it's not necessarily for this because I know we're tight on time,
but is that something that we wanted to,
I'm not sure if we were saying the same thing,
are we going to task the Citizen Board,
Community Services Board to identify those projects
and prioritize them as far as a need?
No.
Explain to me what I have some thoughts about that, Mayor.
I don't think,
I don't think that the Citizen Board should be prioritizing that.
I think they can make a recommendation regarding prioritization if they'd like,
but what I'd like to see them do
is to identify the holes in each of those individual networks
and to identify where we're lacking
and where they'd like to see some emphasis placed
and then allow the council to take a look at that and prioritize it
because we're going to have to prioritize it based on budget constraints,
whether there's impact fees that are available,
whether it's grant money that's available,
whether we're going to use parks,
wrap tax money.
So, I think the prioritization needs to land with the council,
but I would love...
So, I said that...
I used a bad word.
I'm sorry,
because you and I are saying the same thing.
I'm not sure.
I'm asking what is their task?
And if that is to identify the park
and put into an order,
without using the word prioritize,
some needs of their recommendation,
and then the council would obviously have to look at that.
Is that the right task?
Yep.
I think in a lot of ways,
the difference,
what I hear Council Member Wright saying,
is to really take stock of something
or to inventory what is deficient
and what needs improvement,
not prioritizing what needs improvement.
Agreed.
It needs to just be what needs to be done,
and then we can give priority for them
to go back and evaluate.
And there's plenty for them to assess.
So, I was trying to facilitate a project for them
based on Craig's question.
Zach and Melissa will be there tomorrow.
Are you in agreeance
and understand what the will of the body is
based on Craig's original question?
Identify the gaps that exist
in the current system that we have.
And making a list of future needs.
Or something else in open space.
Yeah, but I think each one of those
has its own individual gaps, right?
What is the gap?
I mean, what I would start with is,
what are the gaps in the trails?
What are the gaps in our parks?
Where are we missing a level of service?
I think we start with the most expensive one first.
Yeah, it's got to be the parks.
That's an asset that's declining
if we don't do something about them to improve them.
So, to me, what is the thing
that's the most treasured thing first?
It's got to be parks,
seconds, trails, open spaces, and improved.
That's got to be probably last.
But I think, yeah, sorry.
I agree with you, Council Member Wood.
I think that there is going to be some prioritization
that has to happen there.
But my personal feeling is,
I think they need to be working on
at least those two,
and perhaps all three simultaneously.
I'm just recognizing that there are gaps
in every one of those areas,
and then we're going to have to juggle
which ones we're going to get to first.
I think you've got seven people.
Let me come into subcommittees then.
There's plenty of people to take on some tasks
to go through those things.
I think we need to give them
a level of creativity, though.
I'd like to ask them to think creatively
and bring us things that are thinking outside the box
and not feel like that they're just doing
objective assignments,
but they can be very creative as well
and bring us ideas.
I agree that that eventually needs
to be part of the process,
but before anybody can get creative about anything,
I feel like we have to look at
what we're deficient in.
And I feel like that's what I hear
Council Member Wright saying
and Wood as well.
And I think Zach said, yes,
we're going to have them do
kind of an assessment of it.
But I think we need to look at
what's deficient,
how we're going to fund that,
and then give them the opportunity.
Okay, we want your creative ideas
for this park or this trail.
But I, yeah, go ahead.
I just want to get something
that I have been thinking about
that I would love the Council's input.
I'm sorry, Zach, to get it.
Do you have more slides?
No, I'm done.
Oh, you're done?
I'm just making sure
there's no questions for me.
We're off on a tangent.
We're like down the rabbit hole
going somewhere else for a second.
But the question that I wanted to ask
for the Council,
coming back to Council Member Whiting's
comment about them having creativity,
when we look at expenses,
we could just save the money
and compound it and grow it
and create a money printing machine over time.
We could use it to fund people's salaries
to go out and take care of the fields,
and then you eat up that perpetually,
that fund, every year.
You know, if you hire somebody,
let's say $70,000,
and you bring in $600,000,
there's 10% of your budget.
Or we could look at one-time big expenses
like putting in a trail.
You have to maintain it,
but maybe not as much
as putting the thing in initially.
And so I'm curious
on the Council's thoughts around
giving them a little bit of creativity
in these areas.
Are we looking for,
do we want to have a policy
where we're spending,
you know, money comes in
and then it goes back out?
Are we looking to keep some of it aside?
Are we looking for one-time expenses?
Are we trying to avoid those expenses
that are recurring heavy expenses year to year?
Does that make sense?
I think the financial side of it
is really something that we,
as the budget makers,
really have to come to terms with.
I think their role
is to bring us deficiencies
and when assigned,
bring us ideas
to make those deficiencies better
or to dream big
and have something different.
And I feel like that dollar question
and prioritizing all of that stuff
takes place in the three meetings
that Council Member Wood spoke about.
Maybe one other thing
to be thinking about too
is there are some different categories
in each of those, right?
perhaps we're underfunding our maintenance.
That's part of the problem
is that we're not being able
to keep up with it
because we're either undermanned
or underfunded or both.
And then if we're talking about
the completion of a park,
that's a whole separate issue
and a different funding mechanism.
There's a design element
that has to come into part of that.
to Jared's point about the time of the year.
If we're talking about trails
and laying asphalt,
that has to follow
within a certain period of time
which is going to be right around
the budget time that it completes
and we're fighting to get
every other project done
at the same time.
So prioritization has to be part
of that as well.
Yeah, I'll share a couple thoughts
with you, Zach.
I mean, it really comes down
to the funding mechanism
and how you choose to use it
because impact fees
have to be spent in six years.
They have to be spent
on those things
that you're identified
in the IFFP and the IFA.
I mean, you can't just
willy-nilly appropriate those funds.
You have to already
pre-appropriate them
as you're collecting them.
So you're collecting them
in order to accomplish
and pay for those projects
in a six-year time frame.
I mean, the wrap tax,
if we're going to extract that
through the sales tax use,
which the citizens said
they're happy to see us do it,
in my opinion,
I feel like we need
to expend those resources
on behalf of the citizens
in a timely manner
so that we're not dealing
with a deflation of that dollar
that we've exacted as a tax
through a sales tax exaction.
And so I think it needs
to be put to community use.
And so I understand
your question about,
well, should we just invest it
and we're perpetually
pulling interest off of that?
There may be a case
where that could be made,
but that's a pretty hard thing
for me because I would just
as soon leave it
in the citizens' pocket
as to take it
and invest it on their behalf.
I think there's things
that government should be doing
and there's things
that government
should not be doing.
That's good feedback.
The other thing,
you know,
if you take those funds,
wrap tax dollars,
and you fund salaries
with that,
you now create
a perpetual need
for that resource,
which it will expire
in 10 years.
I'm more just trying
to get the councils
where everybody's at.
So as we're meeting
with them
and laying it out,
so Council Member Wright,
what I just heard you say
is let's spend it.
Let's put it to use
in some kind of,
wherever we're deficient,
right?
I think we should put it
to public use.
If the public
is going to contribute it,
we ought to put it
to public use
in a timely manner.
I mean,
we're looking at funds
that we've been sitting on.
I don't know how long ago
the utility sales happened,
but we still have money
in accounts
that hasn't been spent
that is worth half
what it was
when it was put
in those accounts.
Now,
it's drawn some interest,
so it's earned something,
but it certainly
has been more devalued
in my estimation
than if we had
taken that money,
someone had taken
that money
and appropriated it
to something
that benefited the public.
I think one question
that I would ask
Council to weigh in on
is do we want
to prioritize
bringing our amenities
that we have
up to where they should be?
I have a lot of concerns
and I've heard
from a lot of residents
about how bad
our field space is
and how it's
hard,
hard mud
basically
with little patches
of grass
and kids are getting
hurt on it
and stuff like that.
So like,
whether it's
so that we can
put additional funds
into our existing amenities
or continue
to create amenities
that maybe we're
underfunding maintenance
for,
I think that needs
to be part
of the conversation
that we're having too.
Don't you think
the Community Service Board
can help us
recognize that?
I mean,
their input,
everything's going
to be invaluable.
Because they're going
to help us understand
what the community,
I believe,
really,
really values.
Council Member Clark,
to your question,
I think if they're
asked to evaluate
those things
and say,
look,
where do you think
these things are best,
these resources
are best placed?
Is it in field improvement?
Or is it in making
some trail connections
that don't exist today?
What is it that you see
will bring the greatest value
to the community
in the short term
and long term?
What would you like
to see happen?
There's never enough money
in government
to do all of the things
that we would like to do.
And that's why,
Zach,
it's really hard
for me to say,
and I'm a saver.
Stick it away
for a rainy day.
I live on a ton less
than what I generate.
It's just my nature
to do that
and to compound interest.
I like it.
Those who understand it
earn it
and those who don't pay it.
And so I see the value
in that,
but in the circumstance
that we find ourselves today,
I just,
I don't think
that's the right course
of action
for the citizens.
Steve's got some thoughts.
No, I'm,
he's next.
So yeah,
we've got the next portion.
We're going to go,
if we're good with Zach on that,
we'll move on
if there's no other questions.
Oh, we can read that.
And the only thing
I'll say to that is
I'm excited to meet
with the Community Services Board
tomorrow
and we'll give them,
we won't have a lot of time
to dive into details on that,
but we can give them
an overview
and some direction
and then request
that they go back
and think through
and bring back ideas
and come back to you
with parks, trails,
open space,
recreation.
The next meeting
following that,
I think we're going to talk
more about the RAP tax
and that's where
we can dive into
more of those details.
Well, just quickly too,
I think they're also tasked
with the Memorial Day program
that's coming right up, right?
So, I mean,
that's going to be
one of their first jobs.
That's in a month.
It's a little less than a month.
We're going to talk
about the Memorial Day
and Pony Express days
immediately
because those are two
that are coming up fast
and then give them
an overview
of several other,
of all the focus areas
that they'll be tasked with
and then give some assignments
and I'm excited.
We'll have some built-in
subcommittees basically
as volunteers
that they can help
with our various projects
and, yep.
Okay.
So, next is facilities.
This isn't really me,
but the only facility
that we have planned
right now
for this next fiscal year
is the wastewater treatment plant
admin building.
Can you teach other departments
how to budget like that?
Right.
I don't know if, Ben,
if you have anything
to say about that
or anything to expound on.
Sure, I can share
just a little bit
and that's mostly
what Brad has sent me
as far as
the specifics on it.
It's right now
what's being planned
is a 21,000 square foot
office building
with 16 office spaces
and 22 cubicle spaces
in that new admin building
and we're going through
the value engineering
with the design
right now
with our engineering firm.
Okay.
Any questions
about facilities?
We'll jump over to this
and then if you do
then we can go back
but these are just
what we're calling
administration projects
but just because
they don't fit
within any of the
specific departments
necessarily.
So specifically
for the 2027 budget
we've proposed
500,000
for the civic campus
and that's really
the first phase
after the master,
the downtown master plan
that we did
the next step
would be
you know
Council Member Whiting
Mayor Gray
and Evan and I
talked with
an architect
down in St. George
to get some ideas
on okay
what really is
the next step
if we're not
dead set on
we have
the funding
ready to go
build City Hall
how can we get going
and not just wait
for that
and so
they really suggested
concept architecture
programming
that's
that's the interior
use of the building
and all the sizing
and everything
and a feasibility
portion to that
and we can also add
you know utilities
maybe some
utility designs
on the
off-site utilities
as well
so
that's to get us
moving on the
civic campus
land acquisition
we're adding
we're proposing
two and a half million
to go for land
acquisition
and that's
some of that
is property
that the council
has
somewhat recently
asked us to look
into
and
some of that
is up near
the property
that we purchased
for the public
future satellite
public works
campus
there's additional
property there
that's possible
and then other
property that we
may need
for future
facilities
for the city
and then
we're putting
one million dollars
in for
relocation
of the rodeo
grounds
of course
there's been
talk of
partnering with
the ACUB
army compatible
use buffer
program
they have
several other
names as well
sentinel landscape
and our portion
would be
approximately
a million dollars
if we're able
to tap in
and use
ACUB funding
and sentinel
landscape funding
for that
so we put
that in there
and then
this last one
is
design
and
like initial
design feasibility
for
a field house
ice rink
offices
for
what in the future
would be
community services
but could be
public safety
offices
in the meantime
we've talked
about that idea
at least
at the visioning
meeting that we had
whenever that was
a while back
in the winter time
and then
Kimberly's probably
told you I'm sure
that we're working
towards a five year
plan for our
capital projects
and we're not
quite there yet
but we're
so we do have
like on these
that have a
phase one
or a phase two
and we're showing
in 2028
or 2029
a lot more funding
for actual construction
but we're
today we're just
showing you the
proposed budget
any questions
on these projects
or any other
others that you
think should fit
within this
is the intent
that a field house
and ice rink
and offices
be paid for
with RAP funds
I think
the idea
is
we could use
various sources
so
the county
has some funding
available
through TRCC
funds
Ryan Smith
has some funding
available for ice
rinks
the state
has some grant
opportunities as well
certainly we could
look at RAP tax
funding for a portion
of it
for something like this
we probably end up
doing some sort of
bond and then
using some RAP tax
funding
as well as other
maybe park
impact fees
as well
to help
pay the bond
each year
at one point
we had talked
about kind of
doing an assessment
with our survey
company that does
the surveys for us
and asking the
residents what they
want for recreation
and park
programming and
different things like
that and I know
we haven't done that
yet but part of me
feels like
before we put a
chunk of money
into design
for something
we should find out
if this is
what the residents
want in a
scientific way
not just anecdotally
what we've heard
in passing
so
and maybe
maybe I'm the only
one that feels that
way but
I think as we look
to design
and different things
like that
it would be useful
to know what
our residents
actually want
and I know
that we started
not me
but we
someone here
started
talking with
On Point Insights
our survey group
about that
and
I think
it was either
put on hold
or anyway
those conversations
started
so we can
certainly go back
and start doing that
but
if that's the desire
of the council
is to do a survey
related to that
specifically
I want to make sure
I leave enough time
for Kimberly
to wrap us up
with a few things
I'll just make sure
that we're all
on the same page here
because I feel like
there's a little unrest
on maybe this entire page
but
I'll start at the bottom
because
really this started
with the ice rink
and it's because
there's a large chunk
of money
and I know
I've had conversations
with most of you
that could pay for
depending on what
this looks like
a lot
of this
so
we can go ask
the residents
if they don't want
a free gift
or if they do want
I guess
is kind of my question
obviously depending
on the size
we would
upsize it
and that's where
the bond would come in
but
at least
one sheet of ice
and probably
some extra
you'd have to fill me in
because I haven't heard
for quite a while
where that's at
but
the only reason
this was brought forward
is because there's
an opportunity
to do that
and if
we're not interested
in the ice rink
part of this
I say scrap the whole thing
and save Steve
and I
a bunch of time
so
do we want to pursue
what we've talked about
or no
can you
the ice rink
when you say
it's a free gift
from Ryan Smith
I'm assuming
is a half a million dollars
no
can you
can you just
this has been talked about
for the last couple months
I was in a meeting
I believe at the state
I don't really remember
specifically when
when Commissioner Beltran
said hey
we need to put
an ice rink somewhere
I can get
X amount of dollars
from the state
from Ryan Smith
X amount of dollars
from this
the tax
the
the TRCC
yeah the TRCC
funds
which is the
it's the transient room tax
basically
that's used
the room tax
that's used for recreation
to the tune of
seven to nine million dollars
is what they're offering
contributed from
those parties
I think the
one sheet of ice
was somewhere between
nine and eleven
total
if we went to
two or three sheets
it could be
Steve's been looking at this
but this is stuff
that we've been talking about
for the last couple months
so now we're at a point
where do we want to
look into this
or
let's just pull the plug
because
there's about
seven to nine million dollars
floating out there
that we could get
our hands on
if you're interested
if not
by all means
just an idea
so I've seen
that same offer
given to
Lehigh and Saratoga Springs
how do we get
claimed to that
because I've seen
that from both
councils and mayors
and the other
municipalities
it's been offered
to Orem
to Spanish Fork
it's been offered
to every single place
in the county
and none of them want it
and I said
to Skyler
well nobody's offered
that to us
we reached out
that's when I started
the conversation
with the council
and said
is this something
you want us
to look into
and that's
where it was at
so
so what do we need
to do to say yes
to them I guess
and then for them
to say okay
it's yours
well right now
it's down to two people
according to what
I've heard
it's Orem and us
they're kind of
racing to this
and I think Steve
maybe you could
address a little bit
more
I think that's
what the $30,000
is if we can say
yeah we want it
and here's our design
and this is what
we're going to do
I think we'd get
allocated the money
is that
am I close
I don't know
what
the total amount
of funding
that's available
he's kind of
danced around
with that
with me
I think it's less
than what he's
saying
than what I've heard
but
he did tell me
the long
kind of
the longer you wait
the more money
is available
through the TRCC funds
those transit room
taxes at the county
but
his original
proposal to us
at least when he
talked with me
was
you should do
one ice sheet
out there
in Eagle Mountain
and then they were
trying to get more
somewhere else
like in Orem
so under that scenario
it was going to be
two million dollars
to each municipality
that would do one sheet
and he was kind of
trying to get everybody
to do it
I think
everybody except
Warren and us
basically pulled the plug
Lehigh said no
Saratoga never even
entertained it
they don't want it
if
the county would rather
be central
between the Salt Lake
ice sheet
and the Provo ice sheet
which makes more sense
to be Lehigh
Saratoga Mountain
that's what they've
been saying
if we're in competition
there might be a chance
they split that
we get four million each
you know
what do we have to put up
I guess
is what I'm trying
to understand
well if there's
if they're
I'm blind
yeah we're showing
well we're showing
there about
eleven million dollars
the estimate
that Commissioner
Beltran had
was about
ten million dollar
cost for
a one
a single sheet
a double sheet
was somewhere
in the sixteen
to eighteen million
dollar range
and when you say
sheet
we're talking
rinks
like one full
rink
yep
I know
he calls it
a shink
but a hockey rink
or a
yep
okay
yeah
and so
so if you're asking
how much
we would have to put up
let's say we do
a single rink
that's about
ten million dollars
if
if they're only giving us
two to three million dollars
from the county
there's about
a half a million or so
from Ryan Smith
per sheet
is what I've heard
but it could be more
and then from the state
so I think
we could get
half or
or so
of that single sheet
now I don't know
if you've heard
differently mayor
but
to me
I was interested
in okay
if we're gonna get
some funding
maybe half of the funding
for an ice sheet
then why not build
something additional
with it as well
a gymnasium
field house
whatever you want
to call it
attached to that
for economy of scale
build it all
all at once
with the offices
and everything
but then we're talking
then we're talking
maybe
I don't know
fifteen to twenty million
cost for all that
maybe twenty five
I don't know
what the
what would the
field house
that's what would be
determined like
what would go in there
you're talking about
basketball courts
yeah I call it
a field house
but our biggest need
probably
is basketball
okay
because the schools
we rent all the schools
and some schools
won't rent to the city
yeah
and junior jazz
is a ton of kids
but
there's opportunity
to do other
indoor sports
volleyball
indoor soccer
I think that would be
pickleball
yeah I think
I like the direction
where this is going
so
because originally
I think we were thinking
field house
with offices
was the original idea
now you're thinking
okay let's combine it
together
field house
ice rink
offices
and that's beginning
to make more sense
to me
it's basic
I mean
I don't know
we want to go there
it's not a full rec center
it's something different
right
and it's
it's a
it does meet
part of those needs
part of it
we need to do things
that are unique
in Eagle Mountain
and an ice rink
would make us unique
in Eagle Mountain
so to bring that back
that's why there's
$30,000 in there
to figure out what that is
are you in favor of that
that's really the question
that you're trying to get answered
right
yes
because if we're
we don't want any of it
yes
pull the plug
because I don't want to waste
time even looking at it
anybody else
yes
there's two yeses
sure
so it's going to cost us
$30,000
that's an estimate
to look into
feasibility
it's very rare
that we have
other entities
willing to match
dollars
I mean
I've worked in the
retirement space
where I always tell people
take the free money
when you can
I just think
we need to be
considerate
I'm sorry
go on
I was going to say
I just think
we need to be
considerate
about how we're
funding things
and getting
getting to our
our half
so
and as far as
our half goes
we can certainly
approach
big companies
and other
other potential donors
as well
and try to get
and don't let this
get lost on you
ongoing expenses
will be ours
according to Skyler
as far as the ice sheet
it should pay for itself
I'm just saying
don't let it get lost
yeah don't let it
get lost on you
the ongoing expenses
will be ours
I think to your point
Councilmember Huish
is we need to be
mindful where that
rest of the money
is coming from
because $2 million
to like a $20 million
or even a $10 million
isn't really a match
and $2 million
seems very shaky
at this point
because it does not
feel like the numbers
of what's available
is really clear
or that we have
access to that money
so yeah
I'm willing to
dig into it
and find out
what is possible
but I think
in the meantime
we really need to
figure out
where these funds
are coming from
because it would be
a huge travesty
to me
if we built
a field house
so that it would
have field space
but our fields
that we literally
have already
aren't in playable
condition
and I want us
to keep that
in mind too
so one of the things
that I would suggest
if you guys agree
is make sure
before we spend
that $30,000
that we get a commitment
from the county
on yes we have
an approval
but I want to know
are you committed
because I'm going
to tell you
I have personally
been putting a lot
of pressure on Skyler
saying are you going
to keep flirting with us
or are you going
to go with us
because if you're
going to sit
and string me along
because you'd rather
it be in Lehigh
then I'm out
and so I've been
telling him that
all along
that commit to us
and he told me
that he was going
to call Steve
which I don't know
if that's happened
but I have been
putting a ton
of pressure
that we want
the full match
which like I say
is between
seven and nine
if he's going
to tell us
that oh we're
going to split
with Orem
then I don't
know that I'm
as interested
and I don't
want to spend
the $30,000
if we're not
committed
that we're
the chosen city
for instance
so I think
that's what
that I would
are you saying
that you think
we ought to put
a condition on that
that we're willing
to entertain it
if we get a letter
of commitment
from the county
to give us
the full funding
that they have
available
I think
some sort
of a commitment
at least
which would
encourage you guys
to start
pressuring as well
I've been
pretty hard
on the county
to make sure
that what are we
doing
and I don't know
if you have
greater insight
since then
but
I don't
you know
he texted me
we texted a couple
of times
somewhat recently
but that's all
Do you know if Orem
is conducting
a feasibility study?
I don't know
the level
that they're going
to I know
they were interested
according
to that question
and I'll tell you
a little more insight
in a few minutes
and then
to go back
to that list
real quick
so I know
we got a
I think Kimberly
only is here
to answer questions
I can't go back
to it
but it's
because we're
on a different
computer now
one I don't
know anything
about
and I just
want everybody
who may watch
this
that's not
driven by me
but if Brett
wants to
I'm working
on that one
I mean
I think
I've had
some conversations
with individual
council members
Ben and I
met with a couple
of representatives
from different
entities
and I think
we're going
to be able
to pull
pull some
additional
resourcing
from a couple
of different
entities
to help us
perhaps relocate
that
so I'll
talk to each
of you offline
give you
maybe an update
on those conversations
what was the other
there's the rodeo
the ice sheet
and the
yeah the civic
civic campus
field house
ice rink rodeo
and
the civic campus
is one that
Craig and I
went to dinner
while we were
in St. George
I thought we could
get started
with was it
only $50,000
so the $500,000
it's $500
but
yeah we could
we could certainly
reduce that I think
we talked
down in St. George
about $50,000
and I think we could
probably increase
that a bit
to expand
and do utility
concept
and a little bit
more
but
they said
$50,000
they could do
this is just an example
not that we're going
with this group
necessarily
but $50,000
could get
the programming
and a concept
architectural design
and the reason
for that
so you understand
is that
because we need
to have
something
that everyone
can bid
apples to apples
so we're going to
start with one company
to give us
you know
an idea
of what the civic
campus looks like
and then
they may re-bid it
or someone else
may bid it
but we want them
bidding apples to apples
what this looks like
is that a fair statement
yeah
and we don't want
to dive in
and do a full
architectural
and get a CMGC
on board
and then not have
the funding
to build it
for two or three years
but at the same token
I'm wondering
if the $500,000
is in order to
to also
because it will happen
within the year
I suppose
it will start
the design as well
right
we'll actually go to bid
and then award
we certainly could do that
is that what the full $500,000
is for
and if you didn't
use it all
on studies
and whatnot
you could use it
for infrastructure
as we're doing
Mid Valley Road
to be able to put
sub-ins
and all that
type of thing
so that we're
more prepared
so it's more or less
just kind of
putting a little bit
more money aside
so that we can
move the City Hall
project forward
correct
is that
and we could
we could do
some site prep
if needed
after
after we get
some initial
concepts done
any question
if there's nothing else
I think we're good
to go to Kimberly
right
and mine is
it is a continuation
and a recap
and we're out of time
so what I wanted
just let you know
because this was the
kind of that
beginning of funding
I'm going to send
this sheet out
so that you can
look
at what kind of
these future costs
are
for the next five years
that we're kind of
anticipating with some
of these projects
okay
and then
with that
you'll get
I just have to
find my mouse
we're going to need
to have
maybe a conversation
that we can continue
on like the agenda
and stuff like that
but this is our
programming that we have
for the utility
cell proceeds
so
everything that we have
committed
we already talked about
on those plans
that were there
for projects
and stuff
but what we do have
still is $3 million
that's currently
not committed
to anything
on the list
if it says committed
it
it means that
it has been committed
towards that purpose
but nothing has necessarily
been started with it
it's not currently
in a budget anywhere
it is just
kind of committed
for that particular purchase
purpose
the ones that say
assigned mean that
they are currently
funded in this year's budget
for 2026
of that
those resources
when you guys
were talking a little bit
about your utility
cell proceeds
so $13 million
is originally
what came in
when that happened
and 100%
of those funds
were programmed out
at that time
most of it
most of it happened
what you had
was some big chunks
that didn't happen
one of them
was originally
there was
$2.6 million
that was committed
and assigned
towards a rec center
of which later
the council
again
there had been
decisions
that had happened
from 2015 forward
to not really
move forward
with that
at that time
so that money
got pulled
back in
and that's part
of what makes up
that unassigned
funds that you have
we had some
other programming
where we tried
to do some
match funds
for neighborhood
parks
where we could
try and say
if they were
able to gather
money to improve
the amenities
at their neighborhood
park
then maybe the city
could do a match
it wasn't able
to really progress
and move forward
the money that came
back from that
was about $900,000
that was there
so those are
some of those
bigger ticket items
that came back
to make up
what is unassigned
at this point
that you have
for there
so as part
of the conversation
when you're looking
at what are
these things
that we have
what do we want
to do
what are the
connectivity things
you want
with trails
or with those
open space lands
that we have
there's a lot
of things
that really are
on the list
a lot of things
we've talked about
but this is money
from that utility
cell proceeds
that is currently
uncommitted
or unassigned
to a project
that's supposed
to be moving forward
that we would want
to keep in mind
then in fund 47
which is our capital
project fund
part of it
makes up this
but we also have
about $8.4 million
that's over there
that is currently
not committed
or assigned
to a project
now of the list
that we showed
just a minute ago
let me get this one
can you restate
that again
we have $8 million
in our capital fund
project
that's not currently
assigned or committed
don't we have to
assign it every year
so what it was
let me pull over
is that
as we have projects
that finish off
right
and that money
gets re-released
and stuff
so right now
I know that's
really super tiny
and we don't have
a lot of time
to dig
into it
but we have
this $8.3 million
that is not
currently
committed
towards a project
that we would
want to look at
and
and then
there are some
where we have
funding that is
currently committed
that it hasn't
moved forward
I think the only one
let me think
if I've got that one
up there
maybe not
we have this
and Jeff Weber
isn't here to be able
to kind of state to that
but like for example
we have a million dollars
roughly that we've been
carrying forward
for a number of years
because we had this project
out at the public works yard
where we really wanted
to get this paving done
and be able to handle
some of the drainage issues
and at the time
when this project
came forward
I think originally
it was like $1.2 million
and it included
the fuel storage tank
the council asked us
to hold off
on doing the paving
and the improvements
to the yard
until a facilities
master plan
could come out
that we could look
at what we might
use that land for
so that we weren't
paving and then
digging things back up
so we moved forward
with the council's approval
and we put in that
diesel storage tank
but we have a million dollars
that's committed
towards doing those
grounds improvements
and I know it's something
that Jeff would love
to be able to see us
move forward with
and be able to address
some of those needs
that's probably the only
project out there
that's really been
hanging on there
on this side
and doesn't have any
traction
that we either need
the council to say
yes move forward
or that you want us
to uncommit those funds
you know for another
purpose or something
like that
and then we can talk
about you know
our fund balance
levels and things
so what will happen
is we're just going
to send you that
five-year list
of those
what we call
like our general
capital project items
where you're looking
to say
okay what money
do we have available
and in this particular
area we want you
not to just be focused
necessarily on 2027
because this is a resource
that you don't
the only way to add
money to fund
for these projects
is to have extra money
in the general fund
that's where this money
comes from
and so as you know
where we're at
we don't have extra money
that we're pumping over
okay
and so that's why
we wanted to make sure
you're looking at
as things are moving
down the pipe
of what resources
are there
and that is also
kind of part of that
conversation of recognizing
why we want to be able
to generate excess reserves
in the general fund
because that would be
transferred over
to help fund
these capital projects
that the city has
that don't have
impact fees
and other resources
that can be utilized
for that purpose
these are those
kind of quality
of life type things
that we're starting
to experience
in our community
so with that
I know that we
do need to close
so I'm going to end
what I have to say
but we'll continue
this conversation
at the
I'll make sure
I'll add an item
to the next
council meeting
for next week
at the end too
to continue some
budget conversation
about this
so
is there any
quick questions
for Kimberly
or are we good
with that
okay
the
just for point
of information
I'm going to
announce this
and I think
Brett's got a motion
but we will
adjourn this meeting
from the hallway
basically
because of
planning commission
there are some
closed session items
that we did want
to talk about
if you guys
are open to that
so once we
finish the closed
session
we will adjourn
from out there
so with that
explanation
I'm open
to a motion
Mayor I move
that we adjourn
into a closed
session for the
purpose of
discussing
items
pursuant to
section 52-4-205
subset 1
of the Utah
Code
annotated
second
okay we have
a motion by
council member
Wright
and a second
by council member
Wood and we'll
start the vote
with council member
Huish
yes
council member
Wood
yeah
council member
White
yes
council member
Wright
yes
council member
Clark
yes
okay we'll
move into
closed session
and we will
adjourn from
there